Hi, Andrea, I'll just join in, just gonna listen.
Sure. Okay.
Thank you.
No.
Oh, hi, Michael. Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Alright, hello, how are you?
I am doing well yourselves.
Doing fine. Um, how is Cat so far?
So far so good. The feedback's good.
Mhm.
some onboarding challenges that we've had on our end. But I think they're getting it. We have to clean up some of the items on how she's contacting people and all that. That's more.
Mixed signals, I think, on our end. Yeah, exactly.
Internal process. Got.
Understood. Okay.
So...
But yeah, it was a...
It was interesting because it was also part of the process was like I was in a meeting with the executives and they're like, who's Katrina? And I'm like, oh yeah, about that, right? It just...
Mhm.
Yeah, I know.
I'm going to be honest, I didn't think they cared, right? So it's like, you know, so I'm sitting there with the actual owner of the company, like having, I'm not kidding, I'm having a beer, right? Like we were off site, I'm just sitting there and just yapping with them and he's just like, yeah, what the hell's up with Katrina? And so I had to explain to him what happened at Jensen and they're like, well, why'd we fire him? I said, no, no, no, no, no, no, we like.
True.
Yeah.
Kour.
Not us. The vendor did it. And they were like, oh, OK.
Mhm.
Yep.
You know, and then, and then of course they start asking all the questions, and I went, I think you'll find this funny, and I went...
Mhm.
Remember how we get annoyed when we do that to our people internally and like the like we say that our customers don't have an opinion.
****.
Right. They were like, yeah, and I'm going.
Okay.
Like.
We're the customer in this case. You know, it's like, okay, that's on you. I get it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, and to be honest, when it's the other way around, there are certain, you know, standards that you wanted to keep in order to maintain that quality. And, you know, unfortunately, he didn't he didn't need that. So.
Yeah, it's, I mean, you know, it's one thing when the customer turns around and says that this person cost me X, Y, and Z, I want you to get rid of them right away. It's another case where, you know, I've had to let people go in this organization and I've had customers absolutely tear me a new one and I'm going,
Exactly.
At what point do you do you think you had a vote on this?
Right, so it's kind of like...
Ashish.
Yeah, I'm glad I get an opinion and I'm glad for the feedback. It's just a matter of, you know, we had, I've had one customer really absolutely tear us a new one. Like, how dare you? And I'm like,
Mhm.
Wow.
They care that much, huh?
Well, that get that particular customer is a bit, I was, I, I was actually, I, I was...
On that side.
Okay.
I'm reading a note from Vance. It's about this meeting, so that's why I was just give me a minute.
Sure.
OK, alright, so yeah, I, I, he's he's a very challenging customer, and it's sort of like...
Okay, you know, I like.
Yeah.
He's like, I need you to explain it. I went, okay. I just stood there on the call. I just said nothing. I went.
It's like...
You did that.
Yeah, he said, you're not explaining. I said, you're right, I'm not, because I don't have to.
But.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's.
Yeah, I get.
I go, this is, this is, this is an HR issue internal to Aqueduct. You don't.
Yeah, sure. And they just see it on how they get or how they receive the service, but the bits and pieces of it, like the nuances around it, they don't. So.
Like.
Correct. I mean, I did want to contribute to the fact that I was like, look, from our end, I wasn't seeing any issues. But again, this is an internal discussion with an internal decision to IT by design. I know I don't have a vote. I can just provide feedback and that's it. So it's, and my feedback could have been just as negative too.
Mhm.
Could have been, this is, you know, so it's, I get how this world works.
So...
I understand. Appreciate that. And I guess the silver lining there is, is they know who the people are, I guess, on that executive level. They know who they are. And I appreciate that. At least, at least they care enough to know.
You're welcome.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, that, that was interesting, you know, and I'm sitting there at the table at a bar going, yeah, about that.
Mhm.
Yeah.
You know, I, I honestly didn't, yeah, I didn't think they cared. You know, I was just like, okay.
It would have been funny.
Mhm.
So...
Gotcha. All right, so that's for Katrina, right? Yeah, so just...
One of the things.
Yes, yep, so that's that. And we think that her onboarding is being successful enough that I want to push. I want to make sure that we are on the same page on this one, though. Obviously, with Katrina, it was we were talking about weekends, right? My understanding is we were talking to Andy as well, and I got a text message.
Mhm.
Yes.
from Andy today. I got a WebEx message from Andy saying, like, hey, I was not clear that I was moving to weekends. And I'm like, no, I got to double check on that. Vance and I are on the same, that's what he was texting me on. It was like, no, we're on the same page. Our understanding was Andy was going to be moved to weekends as well. I need a Wednesday to Saturday and I need a Saturday to Wednesday type scenario.
Abe.
I gotcha. Yeah, I think there was a confusion there because initially I was told by Rodge that Jansen would be moving to the weekends. And then I thought that it's going to be a different schedule with Andy as well. But that's no issue, to be honest. They know that if
All right.
If this requires it, they gotta move, so...
All right, so let me, part of it is, let me hold back on that for a little bit. Yes, I wanted two people on the weekends, but if this is a situation where Katrina is in the position right now, assuming she was going to be working the entire weekend.
Okay.
Mhm.
It was still going to be one person. I think part of it was that if Katrina ever needed like time off, Andy would be able to cover the weekends, things like that. I think that's where I was looking at it from that perspective. So.
While.
I have concern that Andy didn't think that he was going to be part of the weekends. I understand the personal side of it and things along those lines. I and Katrina is moving to the weekend, so let's start planning for that. I do want Andy, though, to be trained to operate weekends when necessary and to understand that our weekend traffic is very, very different.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Mhm, Okay.
So, so for me, I would like to start getting into a schedule where Katrina is going to be on the weekends starting May 2nd.
If that's enough time.
May 2nd. Sure, yeah, that's more than enough.
Yep.
All right, so I am going to ask if it's possible for her to work extensively all next week as well. In other words, I'm asking for no days off. I'm asking for, is it possible for her to work Monday through Friday and to start the 2nd and the 3rd?
Okay. That's okay, but we needed to make sure that she gets two days off. So do you mind if we just have her off on either the 1st or the 30th?
Can't, because I need to make sure that she's properly trained. I was more thinking along the lines of that she'd be off pretty much all the following week.
So.
Like the 4th, the 5th, the 6th, the 7th, instead of being, because what we want is a Wednesday, a Wednesday to, or possibly a Thursday to Sunday. So Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday.
and then take Tuesday and Wednesday off. But in the case of the week of the 4th or the 3rd, it'd be like, okay, take Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, take most of the week off, and then start like either that Friday or that Saturday. Would that work for you or do you need it so that she has the time off beforehand?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, she needed to have like a time beforehand because in the Philippines you can't work more than six days straight. So what we can do is to like have her have like a split off. So on the week of the 27th, Monday, she can have like either the 30th
Got it.
or the first is off and then start working during the weekends on the 2nd and then continue on.
All right, so let me review over with my people on that just to make sure, because I am trying to aim for the second. But let's see if it's easier for more time. Because here's what it is. I've got between now and the 2nd to make sure that Andy and Katrina are up to date on all of our escalation procedures when it comes to the weekends. That is really
Mhm.
Okay.
What matters, right? Is that we are confident. Now, I am being a bit of a jerk on my end on this. I am, the team wants them trained, and then when they're comfortable enough.
Mhm.
Moving to the weekend.
I know how that works. It never happens. So I'm pulling the, no, here's the date, get it done.
Yeah.
Mhm.
So it it's alright.
But I want to make sure that she's got enough time.
Mhm.
to get the proper training as well as Andy.
Let me get back to you on this a little bit later today. I'll email you after, because I need to have a couple of conversations with people in India. I need to have a couple of conversations with my people here on this just to make sure that it's working. Because it could be, we might just move it to the 8th, but I don't want to do that. But I might be forced to.
Mhm.
Okay.
Sorry, so I got it. Labor laws, et cetera.
Yeah, gotcha. And also, we probably have to sort out which day would she be off also during the weekdays. Is it Tuesday, Wednesday?
Okay, that's...
During the week, yeah.
Thursday, Friday, or whichever works for you.
Yep.
Yep. So it is, we try, I want to make sure that we have as much coverage as we can on a Monday because that's our big everybody's in-house day.
So, yeah.
True.
Um, but...
I don't know. I don't know from a service desk perspective is it's going to be that big.
Mhm.
Tuesday to Wednesday would probably be a bit lighter as opposed to Monday and Friday. So you probably want her to start Thursday and then over the weekend.
So, Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday.
Yes, mhm.
Okay.
Alright, and then...
But depends on your on the things you do handle on a daily basis for the Helpdesk side.
All right.
Hang on.
Okay.
I got, I got the little pop up in the corner where I'm like, Andy, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, no peace, but that's fine, that's not, I don't have to care about that.
Yeah.
Okay, see ya.
Yeah, let's do that. Let me, let me, because this was the pretty much only topic I wanted to have today, which was the weekend work and getting it done. Let me, then, I think we got it, I think we got a good discussion on it. She knows that the, she knows the weekend coverage is coming, the request. I had it with her today.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Is coming.
Kip.
Okay, all right. I got what I needed from you as far as the answers of like what next steps are to make sure that this is legal and making sure that this actually works.
This is.
Yes, and also I think it's a good move that we put one person first on the weekend so that they can get the hang of it, dynamics of it, get trained, and then they can do work with each other during the weekdays and because they're just sitting together right now. So they can actually work together and understand those.
Okay.
Yeah, so.
weekend side of the fence.
That's correct. And it's the one thing I do want to make point here is that she will be during those hours effectively alone. There's not going to be really anyone else working. There might be somebody in India for the time being. At some point, she won't be alone. But from a service desk standpoint, from an escalation standpoint, from our weekends, especially like end user services.
Mhm.
End user services, our weekends are dead. This is her taking our networking. And the real issue is the only thing we care about, yeah, the only thing we care about are actual outages with our customers. Like we call them priority one outage, right? And she needs to know what I'm not asking her to obviously troubleshoot it. What I am asking her is to facilitate
Alerts.
Yes.
proper escalation, including, okay, it's on her to open up a bridge. It's on her to contact the right people. It's on her to, yeah.
Incident management.
So it is, and this is something that this organization has not done. Forget done well. They've never done it. They've never leveraged the service desk appropriately. Like in other words, the engineer who's on call ends up doing all that. And I just went, why?
Yeah.
Why?
Right, it's it's not an arrogant or I'm too high. It's like you're busy that they're like that call should already be turned like all that should be done before you get involved.
Kour.
De.
No.
Yes, an on-call engineer should just be focusing on the fix, really, the troubleshooting side of things, not the coordination to get to that. I get you. Do you have, sorry to ask, but do you have like a document for the incident management, escalation, who to caller for?
So, these are the challenges.
Correct.
Mm.
Well, this call is being recorded, so...
I'll find out.
Okay, I mean...
Look, to be blunt, this is the reason why I am here as well. I am here as well to fix this. So it's, yeah, it's, there should be.
PH.
I get you.
Somewhere, right? Yeah, definitely. But yeah, I can...
Somewhere. I don't know. Everything here is everything here is tribal and I got to break that too. I got to everything is one of the everyone's mad about these changes and everybody's mad about and I'm getting them to realize that you're not mad about the changes. You're mad over the fact that the way you've been doing things has all been up here and it's been what you think needs to get done and that this is the right way to do it.
I go, one, it's not the right way to do it. Two, it is 100% bad habits. Three, it's all tribal.
Right? It's, you know, he's like, we have on call. I said, yeah. And I'm like, you don't have on call. What you've got is having a phone call going, are you doing your job?
Old age.
Yes.
Right, you know, exactly. Like, I just had this discussion today with my team where they were like, it's in the runbook. I go, what runbook? And they show me an Excel spreadsheet and I'm like, that's not a runbook.
Hear you. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Ha ha.
Michael, I think you are, you're talking about my life on a daily basis. Like, yes. Yeah, that's true.
Right.
You know, and, and, and like one of the people was like, this is a runbook, and I'm like...
Really?
How many years have you been with the company? They're going 10. And I go, where did you work before that? And they would go here and I'm like.
Cool.
That's why.
That's why. Yeah, that's not a runbook.
Mhm.
Yep, I saw the robot.
I'm like...
Yeah, and I asked someone to create a runbook, and then there was an end to the runbook, like a start and an end. But for them, it's just...
Yeah.
Going on circles, so...
Yeah, it's like you start here, you go here.
And the fact that every company has one, every company, every one of our customers has one runbook and I go.
How is that error?
Kour.
No.
Said it is in a standard then.
So it's certain words and certain terminologies are used around here that I'm going, that's not, this is an Excel spreadsheet, this is a data sheet, this is a cheat sheet. And they're like, no, it's a Romebook. I'm like, no.
Mmh.
No, it's not.
Wow. I wonder what your day looks like, Michael.
Well, I got four, I got less than four hours sleep last night. I'm overly caffeinated and it is 245 and I don't know where the hell did the day go. So it's, yeah.
That beer is definitely needed, so gotcha.
Yeah, but I mind you, I'm also like, you know, I'm hammering the waretos, you know.
Cool, that's good to hear.
It's like, there's nothing of a pair of sugar. And I'm like, yeah, that's okay. It tastes good too.
All right, I think the reason why, and just wanted to let you know also the reason why I'm not showing you any deck because we are in the process of hybrid care. So I know that you do not like that. There's actually nothing to report on because, you know, Kathy just started on. And technically, Andy is also assisting in making sure that she's trained and she does.
Thank you.
what she's supposed to do. So that's, I do connect with them every now and then. She is just having the same sentiments with Andy of, you know, how free they are. But, you know, it's not going to, I told them that it's not going to be the same forever. There will be,
Okay.
No.
task that will be coming. So probably just enjoy it as you can, but you got to make sure that you actually understand the little things that you guys do now. Because on those little things, if you do not know and understand and actually master it currently, then that's a problem, right? Because you only have like what, half of the day.
Correct.
not even half of it. So I already asked her also to use OneNote, make sure that she documents everything because your own OneNote is different from other people, right? Andy is different from hers. So she wouldn't even understand what Andy works on because it's different.
Thank you.
Yu, that's correct.
Yeah.
So it's built differently. So they already started to do that.
And it's in.
And there's, and like you said, there's certain levels of translation here, right? Like you and I are having the discussions where I'm like, what they're calling a runbook here, you and I both know is not a runbook. So it becomes very challenging when the customer turns around and says, this is a runbook and you're looking at an Excel spreadsheet with data points.
Yes.
Mhm.
Right? It's like, yeah, okay, I can understand why that hurts. And I appreciate the slide deck. There are, there will come times where I want to look at it. And I'm definitely interested in QBRs. It is, it is just a matter of that. See, I'm having this discussion internally as well, where they're like, you know, I was like, what are we doing? What is the,
Definitely.
Mhm.
Yes.
Mmh.
What is the service that we're providing here when we go to our own customers and we're showing them a slide deck? It's every single month. I'm like, help me out here. Well, we did our own internal one.
Mhm.
And the owner of the company did exactly what I've been doing with customers. He was like, what does this mean? He goes, and is this what we're doing to our customers? Because we're starting to treat our own internal company, Aqueduct itself, as a better customer, because it is the, to use an American phrase, it's the redhead stepchild. It is the, it is.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Actually, we're starting to move the money around internally on the books to say, no, that money is actually going to the managed services team. It is part of the revenue. It's, you know, the owner's like, yeah, that's just, we're just moving from A to B. And we're like, yeah, but the resources are being spent on that because this is how much it would have been if Aqueduct was a customer, right? And the cost center arguments and things along those lines. So it's like.
Uh huh.
Mmh.
Yes, mhm.
These are things that we're trying to improve as well. And the points I make about slide decks working with other service providers is the point that the owner just made about our own slide decks. So I'm like.
Mhm.
Yeah, it's look, I know what those numbers are going to be. There's no new information there. Or at this time, I know these two are not running at full capacity. But I know that that is a conscious decision that I made.
This is.
True.
Right? So it's like, you know, the value to me is going to be on the weekends to make sure that these things line up. The value to me is when I have them start doing more tasks. The value to me is, you know, what's being dropped, what is it? That's when I care about it. I do care about quarterly business reports because I think from a service desk perspective, a quarter report
Mhm.
True.
Yeah.
has a lot more value than the monthly. A quarter report's going to tell me going like, this is exactly what happened. I'm like, okay, all right, here we go.
True.
Which goes to that point, yeah, to that point that we're on that level now that we're hitting that QBR first QBR, but I know there's just a lot of, you know, moving pieces on your side of the fence. That's why I haven't really talked to you about scheduling a QBR.
But I'm also being.
Yep.
But once you're ready and Vance is ready, and we would probably want, I don't know, if one of your executives to actually attend it, if they have time to, then it would be actually best. So you let me know when you're ready to do that. We do invite CX also and senior leadership of service delivery to be on that call.
so that you actually know the value that was provided. You and I talk a lot, but then we wanted to make sure that even though there was a mishap or there was a gap with replacing engineer, this is what we can give you and more for the future quarters also.
And.
Yeah.
Appreciate it.
So no problem. So you tell me when you think it's the best time to have that KBR since it's April now, it's technically second quarter. So.
Yeah, let me, let me.
Let me skip, let me also get back to you on that only because I'm not 100% back. I've been doing a lot of mixed work and all that. The original plan may have been for me to be out longer, but like things had to get done. So it's, I know Vance has been taking over a lot and it's like, well, because I had to disappear.
Mhm.
Yeah.
So, um...
Mhm.
Everything's good? You good?
No, not even close. But I still got to go back to work and all that. I'm going to ask for the quarterly business report, though, to be in May. I don't want it in April. I want a QBR, but I'm going to be like, yeah, I'm going to ask you to push it to like the first or second week in May, only because I will have a better
PH.
Yep.
Mhm.
Okay.
grip on where I'm going in life, not necessarily working. This is definitely more on the personal world. That way, at least right now, I can't see past the end of April on my own life. And so I'm trying to figure out what's going on. So
Mhm.
Okay, gotcha.
Do you wanna do you wanna push it until June, so that at least we have enough data from first quarter to that second quarter since it's June?
No, I, I wanna see when did you, when did you get you started the first?
The first.
When did IT by Design start?
All with you guys, if I'm not, if I'm not mistaken, it's November, late November, yeah.
I thought it was last year.
Yeah, so do me, do me a favor.
Mhm.
Can you pull a quarter business report including all the way back? So do Q1 but go all the way back to November and just add those numbers in there or is it going to skew it too much?
Kip.
Yeah, it might be because we don't have enough number for those few months, like November and December.
That's fine. I wanted to see what I wanted to see was the scale growth. I wanted to see where it's like, this is where we started in November and this is where we are right now.
Sure, we can, and probably start December though, because we started late November.
Yeah, that's fine. That'll work. Yeah, within the QBR, give me a breakdown of all the months. And then, but yeah, for a normal QBR, let's do January to March, and then the April numbers, we'll just have it in May, and then probably in June, late June or July, we'll have the Q2.
Okay.
Sure.
Mmh.
I, I'm okay with that.
Okay.
Yeah, sure. So for the report that you wanted, would just, do you want me to just send it by email?
No, we can have a quick talk about it, actually. I do want to have the interaction and the conversations. As far as the updates for the weekend work and all that, I'll communicate via email. Again, this is back to we're not a full team shop, so I don't have teams really replying to me or updating me. It's only because we're just not a team shop. This is the first shop I've been in 15 years that is not.
Okay.
Mhm.
like leveraging teams in one form or another. It's just, I turned it off because it's like we're not using it. But yeah, I'll reply an email. I'll either tonight or tomorrow, our time.
Gotcha.
That's cool. So for that report from December to June.
Mhm.
March and, well, 7 March. When do you want to do that? When do you want to talk about it?
So let's make that a form of a QBR and let's talk about it.
Mhm.
I got a day in mine, but I gotta double check.
Excuse me one second.
Sure.
Yeah, I know.
Alex saying you have a meeting right now, like no kidding.
Yeah.
Tell you what, let's replace the meeting on the 13th.
Mae.
And turn that and turn that into May 13th and turn that into a QBR meeting. And give me one second.
Sure.
And let's make it from 2pm.
Hang on.
All right, yeah, let's make it 2:30.
Because I'm looking at other people's schedule right now. 2.30 to 3.30.
Mhm.
Make that particular meeting an hour.
Gotcha. Sure. We can do that.
Alright, cool.
May 13 it is and I'll invite fans and you let me know who at the executive level do you want me to add or you can forward it to them so that we can.
Yes, please.
Yeah, I may I may invite one of the VPs and I'm...
barely certain I'm going to be bringing the director, Vance's peer, senior director of customer experience, because of the feedback on how they're interacting with the customers would be coming from him. So I'm a bit like, why don't you come to this one just for, you know, fly on the wall or to have some questions?
Cool.
So, alright.
Sure, we can do that. Yeah, I'll schedule that. I'll get the deck ready and, you know, all the talking points and we'll see how we grow even from the day that we started. Okay.
Okay, appreciate it.
All right, cool. Wait for your email. Is there anything else? Questions?
No, for today that's it. I appreciate it.
No problem. Thank you very much. So moving forward, Michael, I just wanted to let you know, I'll probably, you know, talk about this as well on the QBR, but I wanted to give you a heads up that Rodge has been, has had a different role now in IT by Design. He's still here. It's just that he moved.
a level higher. So for now, he'll be dealing with me. Thank you. I'll send it over to him. He'll be dealing with me, unfortunately, but soon enough, I'll make sure I'll make sure that I introduce you to the new TTL who'll be handling Aqueduct, but I'll still be here, of course. All right.
Congrats.
OK.
All right.
I appreciate it. Thank you very much.
No problem. Anything else, you reach out to me. Just holler.
Thanks, I'll talk to you. Bye.
Alright, you too. Bye.